[Music]
hello and welcome back to the roads 2000
as always my name is caleb done B and
I'll be your driver on this journey
apologies for the slight technical
delays there at the start but we're up
and running now
and tonight it's gonna be a little bit
of a vanity class where I go over what I
believe to be the best chess games that
I have ever played these are some games
that I really enjoy and I think they
have some instructional value and I
probably know these games better than
almost any other game of chess because I
played them so let's jump right into it
my first game here is gonna be up
against Julian pearl Aiko and I think
this might be the closest to a perfect
game of chess I've ever played don't
know if I'm ever gonna get there but it
started with d4 d5 c4 e6 Knight c3 and
Bishop e7 by Julian so this Bishop e7
line is a pretty interesting one Julian
I think played this specifically because
he knew what I generally played with the
white pieces with the white pieces I
like to play after Knight f6 the main
move C takes d5 e takes d5 and Bishop g5
I was playing this exchange qgd and
putting this Bishop on the most natural
square on g5 now obviously Bishop e7 is
targeted at preventing this move Bishop
g5 so I think Julian played it just to
get me a little bit out of the stuff
that I was normally playing I still
captured on d5 which is pretty normal
he takes d5 and now rather than bring
the bishop out to g5 the bishop can just
come out to f4 as it did in this game
now black has to be a little bit careful
about these pawns he would love to
develop this bishop but he does need to
solve some of these problems first for
example a Bishop f5 Queen b3 might
already be giving black some very
serious issues
so c6 was played first guarding this d5
pawn thoroughly now e3 is very natural
and now the move Bishop f5 comes on the
board and now
at this moment there are a variety of
ways you can play with the white pieces
however while I was vaguely aware of
some of these ways I wasn't very
confident that I knew just exactly what
I was doing and a lot of these lines for
example the main move here is actually
something you might not expect Black has
put this bishop here specifically to
guard the d3 square and so black is very
happy if he gets the trade of these
bishops to go through because this
LightSquared bishop is often one of
White's strongest minor pieces in this
kind of structure with all the pawns on
the dark squares in the center of the
board I've said this before I'll say it
again it's all about this light squared
bishop for white in these kinds of
structures so because of that White's
main moves here revolve around making
this bishop fuel a little bit less
comfortable staying where it's at
guarding the d3 square so believe it or
not the most common move in this
position is actually just the move g4
you just directly challenge this
challenge to this bishop and make it
move away if it tries to stay on this
diagonal well guess what's now comes on
the board in the move of h4 really quite
seriously trying to get rid of this
bishop if Bishop takes h4 you're asking
for a little bit of trouble here with
the move Queen b3 when all of a sudden
this Queen can't really keep an eye on
this Bishop and come over to guard the
b7 pawn so b6 would now be forced and
then this is just not the most
comfortable position Knight f3 could
come with tempo I think there are
various other moves rook takes h4 is
apparently just totally winning if Queen
h4 Knight takes d5 is crushing when this
is coming on the board and if you
capture this Rick is trapped so g4 is
some fun stuff however I figured that my
opponent had probably looked at this and
I had not so I just played the simplest
move which is Bishop d3 and this is sort
of giving black everything he wants here
he gets to trade off the light squared
bishop and has a pretty comfortable GAMP
but I was fine with equality out of the
opening so this is what we went with
here Bishop takes d3 now and now Queen
takes d3 and Knight f6 by my opponent
finally this Knight does get developed
now the purpose of
Bishop on e7 has been served and here I
played perhaps the slightly
strange-looking move already now that my
queen is not on d1 I felt that the move
Knight h5 was going to become a pretty
serious threat to get rid of my dark
squared Bishop as well
so I went ahead and played the move h3
just directly here giving this Bishop a
place to run in case of Knight age 5 now
castles Knight f3 and my opponent
actually plays the move Bishop d6 here
going for a trade of the other bishops
and I'm not so sure that this was
totally required but I don't think this
is a bad move at all by black because
while looking at the bishops on f1 and
f5 that got traded earlier on this was
obviously advantageous for black because
this is my quote-unquote good bishop
with this square being able to control
all sides of the board and while this is
blacks quote-unquote good bishop it's
not really so simple here because really
this Bishop isn't helping too much on
the current square it's on you know
controls some squares on the Kings side
and definitely some squares on the Queen
side but really my quote unquote bad
bishop is turning out to be a lot more
active than this Bishop on e7 it's
controlling more important squares on
the Queen side so bringing this Bishop
to d6 and trading it off actually makes
a lot of sense here from black because
well this is the good bishop versus the
bad bishop this was a very very active
Bishop and that's really what matters so
Bishop d6 here I could have just ignored
the bishop trade and let him take on f4
feet so chose but instead I went for the
simple option again and just took on d6
and castled now my opponent plays the
move Knight B to d7 and this is the
first moment when I would really like to
pause and ask the chat room to think
about this position for a little bit so
obviously objectively it's tough to
claim that white could have any kind of
serious advantage here both the bishops
have been traded off the board both
sides have fairly equal development and
yeah I mean neither King is weak it's
it's tough to point out
specific advantage that white has and in
fact objectively the evaluation of this
position is just equal however I do
think that practically it may be the
white pieces here that have a little bit
of an easier time playing this position
so why is that well it's because chess
is all about plans and here I think it's
much much easier to find a plan for
white than it is to find the plan for
black so with that in mind I'd like to
ask you guys at home to figure out the
plan for white what does white want to
do here and why is it difficult to find
such a plan for black as well what do
you guys think I believe this was the
September nights of 2019 when this game
was played so Daniel is saying rook b1
and then b4 b5 for white rook c1 or a 3
and these are all very very reasonable
moves santa slayer is saying black
doesn't have good squares for his
knights in regards to the second
question I asked so Andrea is also
saying rook b1 and yeah Brooke the one I
think is the right idea here for white
and the idea is of course just the
standard minority attack on the Queen
side we pushed the b-pawn forward we try
to take on c6 and create a weakness over
here for black and now as for why it's
more difficult to find the idea for
white or I mean sorry for black well
that's just down to the fact that we've
traded off so many pieces while the the
pieces being off the board might
eventually help black if he does end up
with this weakness there being fewer
pieces on the board means it's slightly
easier to play the position with the
less space on the Queen side but with
fewer pieces on the board
that means black's plan of potentially
attacking on the Kings side or you know
even driving a pawn down the board these
types of ideas which don't always happen
in these car
bad structures now they can kind of
never happen though these ideas are sort
of never really working for black
because with the absence of the bishops
it's tough to get this King side attack
going you know you kind of need this
random bishop floating on East six ready
to capture on h3 or this bishop on d6
ready to drop back to c7 and deliver
some kind of checkmate for these kinds
of attacking ideas to work so what does
that mean well that just means that
black is gonna have to meet white on the
Queen side and rather than go for active
play on the Kings side and that's why I
think this position is just a little bit
practically easier to play with white
you know White's plan is still totally
functional and blacks plan is now sort
of just to to prevent White's play on
the Queen side and to try to fight him
on that side of the board as well so
rook a to be one was the move that I
played in the game and I do think it's
the best move and now almost every time
in this position has been reached black
has played the same move which is sort
of the standard response to sing a move
like okay to be one of course that move
is a five by Black a5 is sort of the
normal way to slow down these b4 ideas
now there are a few things that you
could do with white Queen c2 makes a lot
of sense to card the a4 square with the
idea of pushing a 3 and B 4 to follow
you can play a3 immediately you just
sort of run the risk of seeing this pawn
land on the a4 square when after b5 and
a night landing on c4 you might live to
regret allowing your opponent to take so
much space just as an example I in Queen
c2 and already b5 is well worth
considering for for white or for black
here once again with the idea of the
night coming here so instead of this my
opponent actually came up with a
different sort of plan Julian played the
move a six and I do think that this is
just a slight mistake by Julian in going
for this plan I think he did this
because he was trying to play for a win
and after a five once again it's just
the sort of game where black is trying
to meet white on the Queen side rather
than you know play for his own act of
play and a6 is actually an attempt to
get some very very active
play with the black pieces so after B
for my opponent plays the move rook F to
e AIT's just a good improving move
guarding efore pressuring III and now I
play the move Knight a four and then I'd
like you guys a home to see if you can
understand
Julian's idea what was Julian thinking
when he played this move a six what did
he want to do here oh yes 2019 not 2020
Jeff in Subic era
see a tsuba Qura says you usually win is
black by storming the kingside so that's
what I was talking about right it's very
difficult to storm the Kings side when
you've traded off these two bishops and
I think that's the huge downside to
playing this line with black it helps
solve a lot of your problems to get rid
of the bishops but it also takes away a
lot of your act of plants with these
bishops that would potentially be very
very strong looking at White's Kings
side santa slayer says be six jonathan
croats says be five Mohammed says be
five so yeah Julian's idea was in fact
of this move b5 that's that's totally
accurate and he went for this position
because it is a lot more imbalanced than
the positions we were looking at earlier
for example in his dream world now I
play the move Knight c5 in his dream
world
this night is on c4 and black is sort of
just chillin right chillin with the
knight on c4 pressuring this guy then
threats of f5f four are coming not so
much with an attack on the King but just
an attack on White's Center with this e3
pond
being a little bit troubled however I do
think that this position is now just
gonna be better for white after this
trade for example if you play the move
Knight b6 here and just sort of ignoring
this knight on c5 well you're not on c4
is actually a lot less relevant than the
knight on c5 and the reason for that is
this Knight is doing a great job of
pressuring a6 it's already threatening
some jumps like Knight p7 in the future
and Knight c4 while it does pressure
certain squares these squares aren't
gonna be relevant for many many moves so
see if you guys at home can figure out
the idea to get an advantage with white
here what do you guys think white should
be doing now that black has ignored the
knight on c5 note that this is not
actually what happened in the game well
Julian played was a little bit better
but I do want to examine this because
it's important to understand why do we
need to include a 6 for b5 isn't just a
waiting move that's a good question so
let's say rookie eights b4 b5 if you
don't include a 6 then the move a 4
might really gain in
in power after a four you're gonna have
to play the move a six anyways and I'm
not so sure that this is totally ideal
for example now a five and Nyepi six is
stopped and then we might just be piling
up on this guy pretty directly and you
don't really have time to play this
because of course I have made a threat
to your B pawn so a6 is preparing to
play b5 kind of regardless of what white
plays and so I play the move Knight a4
to at least get my knight to c5 before
that a lot of people are saying the move
Knight e5 and 95 is not a bad move at
all it does a great job of attacking c6
but I don't think it's actually the the
clearest way to sort of play for the
advantage here and then sorry let me I
have I've kind of lost the thread of
where I was ah here this Knight b6 it's
the same position but I was in a
different line I think the most direct
way to play is to immediately go for
this move a4 and when I say immediately
I don't mean immediately I mean after
okay one rook a one is actually a great
move here for white just getting on the
a file in preparing to sort of advance
this pawn for example now if Knight c4
and a for black is never taking this guy
and white is taking b5 sort of at his
leisure you can kind of double up first
if you're really really feeling it and
at the end of the day it's gonna be
white who decides when to open a file
and with this kind of power of decision
white is only gonna open the a file when
it's favorable to him notably black
cannot in turn kind of try to double up
rooks because the minute the stroke
lands on a 7 or the Circa on c7 we can
take on b5 and there's an awkward
awkward pin on the a file so pretty
awkward position here for black actually
with this idea of rook I want an a4 kind
of directly okay so in the game though
Julian does snatch this night off the
board and this sort of loosens my
control over the a Foursquare it loosens
my control over a six as well and it
forces me to decide which pawn to kind
of take back with here now this is a
case where there is very clearly a
better
way to recapture if you take back with
the b-pawn and this is actually not at
all the structure you will are looking
for with white I don't know if you're
much worse here but you very much could
be because suddenly the move C takes b5
after move like a4 is very much worth
considering for black when he would have
connected past pawns on the queenside
no reason to give your opponent this
kind of structure structure instead C
takes is much much better Queen c7 and
now with this capture we actually have
the added bonus of giving our Knight a
nice juicy little square on the move on
on the square d4
now once again try to find the idea the
plan what have you for white here of
course it's actually going to be just
the same thing as we just looked at the
move a4 is what I played in the game and
it's the most direct there are
definitely some improving moves that
white could have played first but I
think a4 directly is perfectly fine as
well 97 was my opponent's response once
again his idea with this structure is to
clamp down on the c-4 square and so now
he's bringing his knight out to this
square and this is kind of what I mean
when I said that practically I do think
this is an easier position to play with
white because when black tries to go for
these active kind of plans trying to
give himself a square for this night
trying to create problems for white
well he's giving up a lot and in this
case black has given up a little bit too
much for the sake of getting this clear
plan and now white I do believe is just
significantly better now I will say that
this next move I believe is the one
major mistake that I made in this chess
game otherwise it would almost be
perfect but the next move I played was
slightly subpar so let's evaluate this
position a little bit I know my
opponent's next move basically I know
he's he's trying to play stuff like this
I don't know for certain that this will
be his next move but I know his idea
right so how do I want to increase my
advantage here and what are some
potential issues
look out for right so in a perfect world
let's say I could make eight moves in a
row this is my perfect world I get to do
this and I get to take care
right this is my perfect world right so
what is stopping me from reaching that
perfect world what is stopping me from
getting to this point what is black
going to be playing because even if you
get this guy here if you just waste a
little bit of time we're back at my
perfect world again right so what is
black gonna try to do to stop me from
getting to this optimal setup with my
rooks doubled on the a file what do I
have to look out for what's this opening
called for white the qgd exchange yeah
it's one of many ways to arrive at the
carlsbad pawn structure
I'm not sure what you mean by that line
Aaron black wants to take on a three and
attack the weak beep on I think mark
means a four and he is pretty close to
the truth here this is sort of the one
threat that Black has in the position
where he is the one that gets to decide
the change in structure so more
specifically after B takes a four let's
say white past here now all of a sudden
it's black with some very serious
opportunities to fight for the advantage
so what black is threatening is to first
take on a four and after a move for
example like okay one just to make a bad
move the threat is now a five when this
night is attacking c5 and this pawn has
no we're good two to go
for example b5 and Knight takes e5 and
black is is pretty much just winning
here so black is not without threats in
the position so the question is what can
you do to make B takes a four sort of a
bad move for black that's kind of the
best way to approach this position
because honestly black doesn't have many
other threats like black can put this
note on c4 but that's about it
right and the knight on c4 isn't really
threatening to win anything it's just a
good night so we know blacks one thread
in the position so how can we try to
stop it there are a few different moves
that are playable here it turns out that
the move Knight d4 is actually the best
move in this position and the reason is
now if B takes a four we can just play
the move Queen a3 and we are defending
all of the relevant squares very very
directly in the game I played the move
Queen c3 and it turns out this is almost
as good but we'll see why there is sort
of a key difference here just in a
little bit so I played Queen c3 the
point being now if black tries to play
this line with B takes a four this is
actually what happens in the game now
I'll play the move Knight d4 and a5 is
going to be met with b5 and this is
actually now a very very favorable
position for
white FCB five rook b5 and look out this
pawn is defended and this pawn is
rolling a difficult pawn to stop now on
c5 and this is sort of the advantage
that I'm playing for with the white
pieces I want to get this strong past C
pawn and use it to win the game so in
the game after 94 my opponent didn't
directly play a 5 and instead put this
rook on b8 first just kind of
challenging my claim to the be a 5
square so the question once again is did
my opponent make a threat does he have a
threat here and the answer once again is
actually yes if I pass then once again
the move
a5 is my opponent's threat well what's
the difference the difference is he's
defending b5
now if b5 cb5 there's no rook be 5
because rook takes b5 Knight takes d5
and Queen takes c5 is picking up my only
chance at an advantage and leaving black
with two extra pots definitely not what
I'm looking for here so once again the
thing we always tell beginner players is
to check your opponent's last move check
if it made a threat and turns out that's
a pretty useful idea in a slightly
higher level chest as well past the
beginner level so how do you want to
solve this threats well I'll tell you
how I solved it in the game solved it
with the move whom has it rook F 2 c1
just supporting this pawn from behind
now the move Knight e5 comes on the
board and we're kind of at a standstill
now so how do you make progress here
with white well of course you need to
pick up this a4 upon that is just the
the cleanest most natural way to make
progress so how do we do that well we
want this right here to support b5 we
want this work here to support c5 and so
we can move the Queen to a3 still
supporting c5 and now coming up to a 4
in the game my opponent opted for the
move a5 challenging me very very
directly on the be 4 square and so of
course I play the move b5 as
intended and what's the issue here well
the issue now is that after CB v we once
again have a situation where after rook
takes rook takes Knight takes it's true
that this is gonna be slightly favorable
for white but due to the slight
awkwardness in the white pieces there's
gonna be an annoying pin here on this
night on the B file and because of this
black is likely gonna be able to kind of
hold this position with best play so
sort of a missed opportunity there for
black this is also the reason why Queen
c3 was a bit of a mistake because if we
go back and I had played 94 here and we
go down the same exact kind of line
let's say let's see what's the order in
which everything happens yeah B takes a
four then all of a sudden I can play
Queen I three and one move instead of
two and I'm just getting kind of the
same line except with a tempo up so
that's why Queen c3 was a bit of an act
in a bit of an and accuracy losing a
tempo in the game so Queen C 3 to a
three now the move a5 comes on the board
and after b5 my opponent very quickly
actually made the fatal mistake in this
game and in that case the mistake was
bringing this Knight to c4 which is not
what you would expect the mistake to be
right seems like this was the whole
point of blacks play but now we do see
that this is the crucial mistake because
it forces my Queen to come to the a 4
square and now I have this earth
defended with the Queen directly so in
the game we see CB 5 or it could be 5 or
it could be 5 and now of course I'm not
going to play Knight takes d5 but rather
Queen takes b5 and this is once again
going to be a very pleasant position for
white now after the move a4 it is white
to move and get a very much winning
advantage here so white to move and
essentially just win the game try and
come up with a few moves generate a line
find some candidate moves don't just
guess at the one move threat because
even if you're correct then a lot of the
time when you get
that the one move threat sometimes the
one move threat is not correct and then
you wind up in a little bit of trouble
so what do you guys think here how do
you win with white only after the game
did I find out mark I thought I played
like a genius in the game can't you
break the pen with Queen d4 you can belt
Ron but then black just takes your
knight
you take black's knight and at the end
of the day it is actually just gonna be
an even material major piece endgame
which black should be able to hold if he
if you play as well definitely you
rather be white in that position but is
it winning probably not
so there's a few different ideas in the
chat room here
so yeah these are all relevant ideas so
the move you don't want to play is a
move a lot of people are suggesting I
really don't like this move rook a1 why
don't I like it well it's it's actually
an okay move but the point is you want
this rook behind this pawn for a couple
reasons number one is an idea some other
people have suggested which is the idea
of playing the movie for efore would
undermine this Knight and it's nice to
have this rook here ready to capture
this night at a moment's notice so I
like having this work on c1 I think rook
a 1 while it is trying to pick up this
pawn sort of for free in many cases I
don't think this pawn is totally
relevant we'd much rather advance this
pawn rather than try to round up the a
pawn in my opinion so the correct move
here is the move that a lot of people
are suggesting as well that I haven't
mentioned it's the move c6 we guard the
d5 pawn and as far as C or Queen b7
being a threat I don't think it actually
is just yet but it's certainly an idea
that black is gonna have to contend with
for example if just a3 sort of
nonchalantly ignoring everything Queen
b7 would be not good enough because this
pawn does end up getting rounded up by
the brook of course though a3 would hang
this pawn which was kind of my point so
instead the move Knight b6 was played by
my opponent and now once again I would
like to ask you guys to find the win in
the game and this is where it's it's
kind of crunch time at this moment in
the game I figured I was probably
winning I just needed to find the right
continuation so what is the right
continuation after Knight b6
now rook b1 is fatal says sue baqara
kura rather cool rah
I don't know I don't speak other
languages very well
well hello tarkman you're welcome for
playing a chess game
everybody says rook b1 rook b1 all right
I guess
rook b1 does win the game but this is
sort of what my opponent was hoping for
I think I think my opponent is hoping
for this when after a three you better
be careful about taking this guy when
you have to have a response to the move
a two turns out Queen takes Queen is it
good enough response to a2 because white
is actually still winning this position
despite being in exchange down obviously
though there are simpler ways to win a
chess game than going and exchange down
on purpose so this is not to be
recommended and definitely not to be
recommended here so rook be one wins the
game but if you guys all saw that you
end up down in exchange I don't I don't
believe you Aaron actually has the right
idea here that I just revealed on the
board but yeah rook b1 here takes a two
is actually a very serious issue Queen
c7 is the only move that wins and then
black gets the second Queen but
unfortunately is unable to deal with the
threats of the pawn queening after
Knight f5 when this is still winning
nine to five by the way the only move
that wins here so hope you guys knew
what you were talking about when you all
said rook be one anyways I didn't see
that in the game so I chose the simpler
way to win which is the move Queen c5
and the point is you are simply clearing
the path for this night to come to b5
and then with that you are very much
winning the game and this quite frankly
is an unstoppable threat if you're
playing with the black pieces I suppose
the best try is to just plant this night
on c8 and hope for the best but Knight
b5 Queen f5 for example c7 and now this
Knight is sort of in the way of your own
pieces if a3 this pawn is very much
capturable checkmate
threatened so g6 and even a move like
rook a one here is is gonna be good
enough a to for example just even King
age two and white can kind of win on
this side of the board this is probably
the best that black could have hoped for
though instead in the game he did make a
mistake rather quickly rather than
Knight c8 he tried the move Queen a 7
which doesn't make the most sense in the
world at this point in time we were both
fairly low on the clock and so Queen a 7
I think it's just a bit of a missed
mishap always a good credo to play chess
is hope for the best
I agree so c7 of course now that the
square has been vacated we pushed the
pawn forward h6 played by my opponent
and now there are many moves that win
Knight a5 wins here more which is the
most direct to just challenge the c8
square I went for style points here with
knight c6 highlighting the fact that
Queen 67 loses a Queen the Queen moved
to a6 and then I went for super style
points rather than play 97 and Queen and
go up a piece I decided night b8 laughs
in your opponent's face say no way no
how are you getting to the c8 square
rook I will block you with my knight
Queen d7 came on the board now and then
finally in time pressure I relented and
played not the most accurate winning
move I am ashamed to say I simply
captured this night on b6 and after
Queen b6 I made a queen the king came to
HSN I gave this cheque and I captured
this Queen and
quite easily won this endgame with an
extra piece of course there were other
ways to win that were maybe more
convincing than a full extra piece for
example rookie one now is going to be a
very good move if a three we do actually
have time to just capture this piece and
capture back and now of course CA is a
full extra queen as opposed to just an
extra piece but in the game Queen takes
b6
Queen b6 c8 clean and that was enough
for a victory the game went on for a few
moves but I did not record them as it
was time pressure and it was sort of
irrelevant to to the game I I did go on
and managed to convert this the the a
upon isn't really all that scary when
the white king is just as in the game as
the black king and the knight can can
help kind of corralled upon so not so
sweet not so scary at all okay so what
is the point of this game the point of
this game I think really is not so
obvious the point of this game really
lies in the trading of the two bishops
here on the surface it feels like the
trading of these bishops it's gonna be
advantageous for black right like it's
rid of this bishop on d3 gets rid of
this active Bishop on f4 those were two
of White's best pieces how can black be
worse when White's two best pieces are
off the board and the fact is black
can't be much worse when those two
pieces are off the board but practically
it does create sort of a situation where
black is sort of searching for a plan
and it's not so easy to find one as
supercro said earlier on in the class
often he wins these types of games by
pushing on the Kings side but this type
of plan can really only be supported
when you have a bishop somewhere on this
diagonal and a fish of somewhere on this
diagonal to help attack a lot of these
weakened squares on the Kings side and
with black just missing those bishops
nothing much to do we saw in this game
Julian went for something with b5
controlling the c-4 square but it did
end up giving the advantage
- white so moral of the story is be
careful when you make these kinds of
traits because if you're not careful
then you could end up in a position
where you just have nothing to do each
trade drastically changes the nature of
most chess positions and so it's really
important well first of all you think
about every move but that you think
especially carefully whenever you offer
or accept a trade of the pieces okay
hopefully you learned something here
about that you know general points and
also about this kind of structure with
the move a for being a key point for
white here there's a ton of value in
being able to control when you open the
a file and that's why white is
significantly better here all right
moving along to game number two this is
a game that I played against the one and
only Katarina named SOVA and I believe
this was from the 2017 bill right st.
Louis open and this is a game that I'm
quite proud of because of things that
happened in real life I love this story
because it makes me feel so cool
it was the Saturday before the Bill of
Rights st. Louis open and Katarina was
actually our Grand Master in residence
at the time and maybe in a youngster I
was like ah why don't I use up one of
these GM lessons that I have so I go in
to take a lesson with Catarina nothing
but respect for Catarina and you know
she teaches me a few things that I was
working on it at the moment and giving
me some advice and then the next
Saturday I go to play in the tournament
and Catarina plays and then I end up
paired with Catarina and unfortunately
for her this is one of the best games
I've ever played and so obviously it did
not go her way and then I believe she
forfeited from the tournament thereafter
you know she's just so disgusted if
she's losing the patzers like me how can
she keep playing in this tournament
anyways the game went d4e six c4 at five
we have a Dutch I go for the move g3
which is the most common move
generally in the Dutch it's a lot less
common to bring the bishop out to d3
against this kind of structure because
black is very solid on these light
squares and so it makes a lot more sense
to go g3 Bishop g2 and challenge the
Queen side of the board instead Catarina
played the move Knight f6 I go Bishop g2
and she plays c6 now sort of
telegraphing that she's going for the
stonewall i play Knight f3
and now after d5 and we have very much
arrived in the stone wall and there are
a variety of ways you can play this
position I go for this move Bishop f4 in
Bishop f4 is a pretty interesting idea
the point is it's going for a very
distinct change in structure that you'll
see a little bit later on now there's a
variety of ways that black can play
against it you can go Bishop d6 directly
which would potentially allow the move
Bishop takes d6 but also might just
allow something like III and the change
in structure I'm talking about is here
we actually usually take back with the
Jeep on controlling this e5 square quite
thoroughly but also leaving this f2 pawn
in reserve so that if needed it can come
to f3 and control some key light squares
in the center and on the Kings side as
well so in the game though Bishop e7 was
Caterina's choice I went ahead castled
and we see castles by black as well
now I actually bring this Knight out to
c3 and sometimes actually this Knight is
a little bit better suited on the d2
square here I don't think it makes too
much of a difference and we'll talk
about why in a moment now Knight h5 was
Caterina's idea and here potentially I
could save the bishop with the move
Bishop e5 but I was very comfortable
going for this structure that I was sort
of familiar with so I just played the
move
III instead now Knight takes f4 is
perfectly playable but rather than G
takes here I think white should very
very seriously consider playing the move
he takes f4 sort of opening up access to
this e six pawn and this is likely why
Katarina did not take on f4 in the game
because this e takes up four threat is
pretty relevant actually so instead we
see ninety-seven by katarina delaying
any ideas of capturing this Bishop and
now I just play the move Queen e2 a nice
improving move defending the c4 pawn
supporting my pressure on the e-file as
well now Knight d2 f6
was played in the game and once again
I'd like you guys to pause and try to
find the plan here for white what are
some moves that definitely come to mind
if you're playing here with the white
pieces what are some of the plans
so black can only defend in the Carlsbad
structure if he has no bishops that's
kind of one way of putting it Beltran in
reference to the previous game obviously
every game is going to be different in
that specific case it's I think it is
true that active plans were very very
hard to come by for Julian there he
managed to come with one but it turns
out it was not a great one but yeah I
think more natural is not to say he can
only defend but just to prepare for the
opening up of the Queen side with a move
like a five keeping the Queen side pawns
sort of restricted for white and then
eventually White's probably gonna break
through over there but black at least
then we'll be ready for the opening of
the Queen side in there it's not so much
that he'll be defending buts
that's a he'll be ready for the opening
up of the position so we'll have his own
activity as well okay a lot of
suggestions revolving around playing the
movie for now you five followed by F 3
and E 4 yeah that's actually not my
favorite idea in this position generally
the chat is like answering all these
questions no problem but yeah 95 is
definitely not a bad move at all
let's say my opponent were to continue
with a move like I don't know Bishop d7
now if I start playing stuff like f3
Knight takes f4 is going to be a lot
more problematic on the second play f3
you're weakening a ton of dark squares
now if I go for the same sort of
business with eat takes f5 sort of the
Stonewall move you never expect to see
might come on the board with c5 and you
are weakening a lot when you play this
move f3 I did mention this as a just in
case you need to control these lights
course but that doesn't necessarily mean
that this is going to be the plan here
to play for a move like 'if or INF G
takes off for here still a move like c5
and these dark squares are gonna come
under just a little bit of fire so I'm
not a huge fan of f3 95 is always gonna
be a fine move in
position though the plan I was actually
looking at is the plan of once again
playing on the queenside was stuff like
b4 and b5 so moves I would definitely be
considering moves like herd FC one who's
like her AC one moves like C five moves
like a3 going for b4
these are all things that I would very
very much be considering in the game in
the game I chose rook a to be one rather
than any of those options and this is
just going for much of the same stuff
there was a question though why didn't
Caterina take on c4 and reinforced with
b5 and the reason here is generally
because of this monster bishop sitting
on g2 sort of lying in wait for black to
do just this after do you take c4 you
are immediately running into 95 when if
you play b5 see six things if you don't
see four hangs and you're just really
giving this bishop a little bit too much
activity here so that's why no takes on
c4 however in the game we see Rick a b1
a 5 by Catarina and then I actually go
for something very very similar to what
we saw in the last game I played the
move Knight a for trying to play the
move not Knight c5 in this case but
rather c5 and Knight b6 going for just
total domination on the Queen side and I
do think this is a perfectly fine way of
playing in this position now in the game
Katarina hit me with the move D takes e4
highlighting the fact that Queen takes
c4 might be a little bit of a mistake
tactically this is actually working out
for black just the move b5 is going to
be picking up a piece here if you think
you're being very very clever with Queen
takes c6 I'm gaining a tempo on the rook
joke's on you
Bishop d7 gains that tempo right back
and is still winning this night for free
so no Queen takes d4 available and now
that Katarina is sort of committed to
this I do a total 180 on the plan which
is something that you shouldn't be
afraid to do in your chess games and
that's why I like this game that I
played so much is because
I did this sort of immediately and what
do I mean by doing a 180 on the plan
well the plan before it was to play 94
in c5 and 96 obviously that plan is sort
of out the window once the move D takes
c4 happens now does that mean I'm sort
of committed to having this night on a
forint over justifying it well no it
actually doesn't and so in the game I
played the move Knight c3 and Knight e5
is obviously a very very good move and
it might have even been slightly better
than the move Knight c3 but the point
still stands
Knight c3 isn't a bad move and the point
is whenever there's a serious change in
structure like with D takes c4 you
really do have to sit down take a lot of
time and reevaluate what's going on in
the game and the fact of the matter is
this knight on the a4 was really only
hindering my ideas and so I brought it
back to c3 and as soon as this move D
takes c4 was was sort of played so once
again my past two moves were knight i
for Knight c3 and somehow white is still
doing doing well here now is that to say
you should always kind of just repeat
moves aimlessly like this no of course
not but I do think it made a little bit
of sense at least here
even if objectively ninety five was a
bit better so the moral of this story is
very very much to reevaluate every time
there is a change in structure because
you might just find that what was
working for you before is not working
for you anymore and you might have to
adjust a little bit in the game katarina
plays the move Bishop d7 defending the
c6 pawn
sort of preparing for a move like b5
however this is not true Bishop d7
probably would have been a good move
instead in the game she played in the 95
which is also fine and now I snatched
this pawn back before it was too late
you know kind of get it while the
getting's good
so I take on c4 and now she plays the
move Bishop d7 still preparing to kind
of expand over here on the Queen side so
okay let's read
group we have one nothing we have one
our pawn back I should say on the sea
for square and now we need to come up
with some new ideas for white so what do
you guys think
what should white be doing in this game
now what are going to be the idea is
here not only five is almost never bad
here yes
fair enough fair enough
don't repeat aimlessly repeat with a
purpose Beltran has it Beltran has it
figured out
so I'm seeing a couple one move
suggestions that's not really what it's
about we're trying to come up with some
kind of a plan here
viral stigma says to trade on d5 because
his night is better her night in this
case rather bring out the rook so these
are some you know sort of short-term
ideas as far as long-term plans here
remember with this move rook p1 and 9a
for I was looking for long term plans of
expanding on the Queen side stuff like
this you know long term plans where I
was aiming for space over here then we
had this drastic change in structure and
so the plans sort of changed and so here
now after Bishop d7 we've regained the
pawn and it's time to come up with these
long-term plans again mark is now saying
go for an attack on the Queen side after
the e4 break then he says never mind
that's a bad idea man he says don't
trade then your Bishop would be bad a
three by Super Cara so still Kuro rather
going for this a 3b for stuff is
certainly one idea and in this
particular position I decided that yes
still the Queen side is where I wanted
to be playing it's true that sometimes
some efore breaks are definitely going
to be well worth considering for white I
thought that you know why it isn't
really risking anything here and I just
wanted to sort of lock down on this
Queen side altogether but the move I
actually started with is now that we've
had a trashed exchange in structure once
again it's time to reevaluate whether or
not I'm happy with the current state of
affairs and I decided that is actually
no longer so happy giving up this bishop
on f4 now the things I've opened up a
little bit black would very much like to
be able to use some of these squares for
his pieces including the d6 square as
well so I play the move Bishop e5 a
rather than 95 with the idea of just
preserving this Bishop so once again
morale the story reevaluate the entire
position once a change in structure
happens no longer happy with losing this
Bishop I
chose to save it with the p5 now black
with the snide and h5 being useless and
decided to bring her knight back to f6
and now I play the move Queen e2 just
sort of getting out of the way on the
Queen side this Queen was perhaps while
it looked actively placed sort of in it
in the way of all my other pieces Bishop
e8 now by black is aiming for some
activity and now I play the move 91 not
ready to give black this exchange and
ready to come closer to my plan of
control on the Queen side of the board
Bishop h5 was now played Queen d2 and
now b5 by katarina taking this Queen
side space so once again this is a
pretty dramatic change in structure but
thankfully I was sort of preparing for
this one because now 93 is very very
natural just keeping the seat pawn
backwards and now White's play is going
to be extremely clear White's play is
going to be attacked the C pawn win the
C pawn win the game and the fact of the
matter is this is just a dreadful
position for black at this point Black
is the one with all the weaknesses this
week pawn on c6 Black has less space
this Bishop on e5 is a great piece a
knight on c5 is going to be a great
piece and the rest of black's pieces are
sort of just just disjoint it right this
Bishop on h5 this Bishop on e7 you know
what how do they make any sense together
they really don't so a great position
here for white already and so how did we
get to such a great position out of the
opening against Katarina and M Silva
well some of it is down to the stone
wall thing a little bit suspicious
sometimes but a lot of it I think is
down to these moves like D takes c4 that
Katarina played sort of just trying to
prove that 9 a4 was somehow a bad move
when you over commit to things like this
and try and refute your opponent's ideas
directly that's when you run the risk of
you know actually being worse yourself
some ideas and chests don't need to be
refuted you just need to find your own
active play elsewhere on the board so I
think this move D takes c4 is sort of
the beginning of the end here
katarina and now b5 is actually being
very very friendly to me if she left
this pono in v7 it might still be a
slightly awkward position for black but
at least you know this b7 pawn being
week it's a lot better than this e6 pawn
being week cuz it's a lot harder to get
to the b7 pawn but in the game we did
see b5 now 93 and b4 was actually once
again being a little bit too friendly
now I am actually quite happy to put
this Knight back on a4 because it makes
sense with my pieces once again heading
for c5 97 was Katerina's choice and now
I just bring a rook to the C file very
very natural rook c8 rook c2 just
preparing to double Bishop back to e8
and rook F 2 c1 this is just the most
natural chest I could think of and it
turns out it's just very very good chess
in this case Ric f7 was her move and
honestly like just look at this position
if you're playing with like look at look
at it from this side right Oh God
flip it back before I puke like this is
so awful this is just so so awful you
can't move any of your pieces and it's I
I just I hate this position for black
which means I was having a lot of fun in
the game so rook f7 was what she come up
with she came up with and honestly it's
not the most useful move in the world
but nothing really is here for black so
rook f7 why not now this is the type of
position where you can do nothing for
like 10 moves with white and your
position is not going to get any less
good so I played the move Queen e2 which
believe it or not is actually like the
best move in the position the point is
Queens just more active on e2 aiming at
squares like a 6 or h5 depending on how
the game progresses and then after
Bishop f6 I decided now was the time to
make my break and so I brought this
Knight to c5 now after Knight takes e5
rook c5 it's Bishop dropped back to e7
and this rook dropped back to e2 and so
we've just taken off one of these pieces
for black now and after Bishop d7 the
issue is after 95 he's running out of
ways to get rid of a knight sitting
on the c5 square in the game she chose
not to capture on c5 which might have
been maybe the best but but of course
now moves like Queen a6 are going to be
sort of devastating for black with this
Queen just getting way too active
although I guess the move rk8 is
playable here in the Queen s to come
back but the point still stands it's
difficult to really do anything here for
for black for example if just a passing
move I think a move like a3 is is
already beginning to open things up
favorably for white with with things
like this to follow but okay in the game
she did not capture on c5 and Shen and
since she chose to play the move Bishop
f8 trying to sort of untangle this rook
and now white to move who sees the best
move here for white
yeah c6 is vici sixes week everything is
just soso week so a lot of people are
saying Knight b7 which is a fun move
Knight takes D seven is being suggested
I am not in love with Knight takes D
seven I I don't know why you would want
to kill this bishop right like why are
you trying to kill this guy for your
opponent you your opponent is so happy
if this bishop falls off the board so
many people saying 97 what's the point
of Knight be seven I'm confused why do
you guys want to play an AP seven so bad
I don't understand and you want to go
here but let's take it I mean you're
still winning but probably why so the
move I played in the game is the move I
like the best still and it's the movie
four and this is a great way of
approaching positions like this in my
opinion your opponent is totally totally
tied down their pieces are all tangled
up getting in each other's way because
they have to defend all these weaknesses
so what do you do well you open up more
lines then you open up more lines for
your pieces to get into play well your
opponent's pieces are uncoordinated and
lacking active squares so II for plain
in the game if F takes c4 this should
take c4 and now these aren't bishops of
dreams Queen g5 was Caterina's move in
the game and unfortunately for her
already this is just dead dead lost
Knight takes t7 was now my choice in the
game I know I just made fun of you guys
for taking off this bishop but here
tactically it is just totally winning
age for Queen h6 and then I could
capture on c6 but rather than do so
which would allow a queen takes c1 with
check not that white isn't winning here
white probably is winning here but I
play the move King g2 instead just
avoiding this line entirely now 97 comes
on the board and now Queen a6 is sort of
disgusting for black once again all the
piece is tied down step
on each other's toes okay rook dd8
was her choice and now I just pick up
the pawn on 85 and it's time to start
collecting some material advantage
Knight f5 was her choice trying to find
some kind of activity over here and I
could have just immediately captured
this guy but I played the move Queen b6
instead now she plays queen g6 making a
threat turns out that this is a threat I
could have just responded to with a move
like King g1 or remove like King h3 and
this would have been perfectly perfectly
fine instead here I kind of ruin to the
beautiful game I had played so far as I
often do I sort of panicked and went for
what I thought was going to be the
easiest endgame of all time with Bishop
takes f5 now I move like King g1 is
actually just fantastic here you can't
ever take this now because it's not with
check and if Queen g4 guess what the
move f3 is actually going to be really
strong Queen h3 that's a trapped Queen
and if Queen back to g6 once again you
have no threats here and rook c6 is
coming on the board quite quickly but
instead I play the awful awful awful
move and that hurts to see every time
Bishop takes out I gave up my beautiful
beautiful Bishop for this night on f5
disgusting stuff I apologize
Queen f5 I do still get this pawn but
now after Queen e4 check King g1 or xc6
Queen c6 Queen C 66 the unfortunate news
is that while I thought I was just going
to be to clean pawns up here
turns out black is actually winning one
of them back which is not something I
had really bargained for so of course
the move here for black is rook 8/8 I
was like not to worry I knew I was
losing that a pawn anyways
rook takes a 6 is still two pawns up now
rook takes a 2 was played and d5 is the
idea to defend the B to pawn but now my
opponent does have rear k1 check and
rook over to d1 and this pawn on d5 is
not looking quite as comfortable anymore
with this rook sitting directly behind
it and so it turns out that this is in
fact just black winning back this D pawn
in the game I played Bishop d6 rook
takes d5 Bishop takes f8 King takes F
fates and now rook b6 getting behind
this pawn on the B file turns out though
that this is still going to be pretty
good for white here I should still be
winning in this case rook d4 was played
in the game and now after rook b7 this
King is just totally locked in on the
eighth-ranked age six was her choice
now after b3 Katarina sort of panicked
and played the move g5 which is making
the win a lot a lot easier and I'm not
gonna go into this endgame too in-depth
but I will show you how the game
finished here and then if you want to
see this end game very very thoroughly
analyzed stick around for the endgame
class coming up right after this
but in the game I played the move h5
kingi eighths King f1 rook over to e4
and now f3 was my idea of breaking
through making sure this rook could not
stay along the fourth-ranked and also
keep my king boxed out rook III was her
choice but now after rook takes before
it takes f3 kingi to Roxy 3 this is just
now a clean passed pawn and my King has
a very direct path sort of into the game
and the game finished without too much
controversy here with this pawn getting
pushed and my king coming into play over
on the Queen side as such and here I
believe Catarina resigned and forfeited
from the tournament in disgust that is
all for tonight on the road to mm -
thank you guys so much for joining me
here
up next is going to be the endgame class
where I'm actually going to start with
this exact endgame and walk you guys
through it a little bit more slowly with
a little bit more in-depth analysis so
be sure to stick around for that with
that in mind thank you so much for
joining me my name is Caleb Dundee and I
will see you next time
[Music]
you